I think all dudes should [__] dudes
straight up I wish I could do it but
it's like
you know bungee jumping for me I just
kind of I don't want to you know but if
I did I would do it dude like you know
I would do it and I would do it a lot
man like
I I I I think all men should should
absolutely [__] other men so if you're
thinking about it get into that it's
very Pride right now and I was at dinner
with my wife and like we tried to drive
a [__] home and everything was
blocked off and there's not even a
parade happening right now right or is I
don't even know I I think honestly like
more than five gay guys walking around
is a parade because they're just so
parady you know you don't just walk they
like do it like that
so I got out of my car to go to dinner
and a dude in a speedo walked by just
like super gay and that's all good I
think most guys should do that straight
or gay
but I here's my problem with the whole
thing
okay
is that we got back in the car after
dinner went home and everything was
blocked off I couldn't drive my regular
route I had to keep making u-turns just
because guys [__] other guys and it's
like that makes no sense
I want to go you know where I want to go
that way but I can't because guys [__]
other guys
do it
[__] other guys like I said I think all
guys should [__] other guys but I want
to go the roots I go
like if I was gay I swear to God I'd be
like ah pride month it is so it's can I
just [__] guys in peace dude I gotta be
all I gotta be all open in my window
hollering out about it
you know let me just suck some you know
let me just suck quietly
did you like that yeah all right cool
this is it's fine if you tell people but
just don't be all like singing about it
you know
and then I was like driving past a trash
can and it said don't Litter glitter and
it was like
Ah that's litter though right
what's the most number oneiest thing
that's litter glitter Glitters
everywhere always
hey look down you got glitter on you
because some [__] wore glitter in
[__] 2007.
right that you walked by that [__]
doesn't go away I can't drive certain
places and it's super gay and that's all
good I don't even think it should be gay
to [__] guys I think it should be
straight
into guys how did you gay guys do it
because guys don't want to do [__] two
gay guys are just like
ah I'll get to it you know
guys but I don't think that's the
straight male thing right
can you do the thing like do gay guys
are they like can you do you mind this
or like Jesus one of the best things
about being gay is you probably don't
have to do any chores
you know you're just honestly
[__] right
it's Pride so that's kind of it it's
Pride uh in uh everywhere I guess pride
month is every three months I think and
I I feel like maybe I feel this
honestly because I just I live in L.A
and it's pretty [__] gay here and
that's fine I love it
[Music]
congratulations